this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation
about your life and your money i'm your
host george campbell host of the fine
print and entree leadership podcast and
i am flying solo today i am totally free
all by myself i would sing it but the
fcc would take us off the air it's a
free call today and i would love
to hear your questions then phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five again that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five
and yes i am one of the storied
millennials out there and here's the
thing about millennials that they don't
tell you they're scared of phone calls
but to make this show interesting we've
got to hear your voice so give us a call
if you're a millennial especially gen
zers gen xers boomers i'll take them all
but i am one of those millennials and i
was very average when i started here at
ramsay eight years ago
i had forty thousand dollars in debt
and i had the exact average amount of
student loan debt 36 000 of that was
student loans and 4 000 of that was
credit cards
and i grew up in a very normal household
middle class i grew up with immigrant
parents who immigrated from the middle
east
and they conformed to the american
culture real fast
and uh the american dream here's what it
is i want to buy a house i want to have
a good job i want to have the car and
with all of that comes payments and so i
learned that you just live on payments
and you just got to be smart about
moving the debt around and managing your
debt and that is the way to financial
success
wrong
when i started here at 24 years old as
an intern i started following the ramsey
plan i went oh my gosh it was a
different way i don't have to live with
these student loans for the next 20
years which is the average it takes for
people to pay them off
i don't have to be average anymore
and so i got on the plan i started
following these baby steps that we teach
day in and day out
and i started realizing my plan sucks so
why not try someone else's and i did it
in 18 months i paid off my debt i was
debt free and i built that emergency
fund and i started investing for the
future
and our company 401k here and i don't
have kids yet but i met my wife here she
works here at ramsey solutions it's a
beautiful story for another time
and now we have this big hairy audacious
goal of paying off our house in our
early 30s and i'm happy and proud to say
that within a few short months we're
gonna have that bad boy paid off
and i'm not rich i'm not special i never
thought any of this was possible for me
but after following this plan and
realizing that it doesn't take a genius
it just takes sacrifice it takes hard
work it takes saying no to a lot of
things you want to do in order to get
things that you don't have
and i don't want a payment the rest of
my life we've got goals we've got things
we want to do vacations we want to take
organizations we want to give to and i
realize that money problems and payments
were just holding me back and it's
holding back an entire generation of
people who aren't starting families
they're not buying the house that they
want they're not able to do the things
they want to do they're in jobs they
don't even like because they're trying
to make their payments so i wanna talk
to you guys today
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number call us up if
you want to learn how to pay off debt if
you wanna know what to do with the
emergency fund what's the best way to
pay off the debt how do you get started
in investing how do you pay off your
house early i would love to talk all
things money with you today and we are
kicking it off with david in phoenix
arizona david welcome to the ramsey show
yes good morning good morning well good
afternoon here i don't know where you
are phoenix what time is it in phoenix
um it's
it's 11 10. okay you're right we're both
right
how can i help today so my
my question is what to do with my excess
cash that i have in my possession okay
so far we have seven houses and all paid
for whoa and
yeah
so
and we also have
um
five of them are rentals and we're
gathering up about 5500 a month
incredible what's your net worth
um probably just under 300 or 3 million
unbelievable way to go man you're a baby
steps millionaire this is absolutely
incredible
yeah well also i have two houses that
are ours one here in phoenix and one up
in idaho
and they're about a million and they're
paid for also oh my gosh so
so we took some money and got 28
um
28 000 in gold and then we got 13 000 in
silver
and
we're looking at
purchasing some more
but i don't know what to do with it we
got about 300 000 that we could play
with there so you have 300 000 liquid
dollars to play with are you saying if
you sold this uh gold and silver
no
no we got three hundred thousand just
sitting here in cash
yes well do you love real estate in the
bank
yeah yeah we've been doing well in it it
sounds like that's something that you
guys are really into i mean you're at
you're obviously at baby step seven so
this is where you build wealth and give
and you've got tons of options and so i
can't make that decision for you but
what i can do is dig in and ask you what
are those maybe short-term long-term
goals are you married do you have anyone
else in the family that is making this
decision with you
uh yes i am married we got five children
and they're all giving us grand babies
oh that's sweet
so what's the goal do you want do you
want more real estate or do you want to
do something fun you want to take maybe
the kids and the grandbabies on an
amazing vacation and put part of this
into real estate
what are you thinking
well um
we're totally debt-free cars um all that
stuff is debt free
so
we
gather up 5 500 a month
and we can easily live on that plus put
savings away
so
your question or my question is i got
three hundred thousand dollars and we
are thirty thousand dollars and we're
looking at
um
maybe investing that not necessarily in
more real estate because i'm i'm 68
and
uh we do our own rental clean up and
you know
screen our tenants and
so far we got good tenants and they're
paying without any problem
and
i don't know we got this 300 000 and uh
should we buy more gold or silver or
i if if i'm you i'm not doing that we
don't recommend getting into gold and
silver i'd rather see that in good
growth stock mutual funds you can do
that in a brokerage account if you want
to keep it fairly liquid and it's going
to be in there for you know four five
six years uh but if i'm you i'm sitting
down with my wife and i'm going hey what
what could we do that's absolutely
incredible because this is the part
where you get to live like no one else
because you guys have lived like no one
else so have that conversation start
dreaming and maybe it goes to four
places maybe you go hey we're going to
take a crazy vacation with all the kids
and grandkids we're going to do some
real estate investing we're going to do
some mutual fund investing and we're
going to get a few toys and we're going
to give generously
and split it up yeah it doesn't all have
to go to one thing uh but i think this
is a conversation that you and your wife
have you've done so well there's no
wrong answer here other than going into
debt
but i think based on your goals and the
things that you want to do and how you
want to leave a legacy this is where you
get to do that man you're an inspiration
david you have done so well three
million dollar net worth three hundred
thousand dollars sitting in cash you're
who i want to be when i grow up david
thanks for calling in this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at zip recruiter dot
com slash ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsay personality host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast it's a free call this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five call me up with your money
questions i would love to have a
conversation danielle joins us in
chattanooga tennessee danielle welcome
to the ramsay show
hey hey
all right so um
my husband i work for the same company
and in january they're finally going to
be offering a 401k program um we're at
the point in our baby steps that we can
go ahead and start investing in that
what i was wondering though would it
make more sense for us to put them
basically have one account versus each
invested in an account just because the
way the interest works or would it make
more sense for each of us to have our
own account
they're doing a five percent match on it
what was your thinking in doing it all
in one account
um i wasn't sure if the interest would
compound better because of having more
in one account versus having it split up
into two accounts ah
now the the interest won't make a
difference if you've got ten and one and
ten in another or twenty all in one it's
still going to compound at the same rate
when you put it all together in the end
so on that's on that side there's not
going to be any benefit there so if that
was the only reason you were thinking
about doing it in one i would go ahead
and do both you're going to get the
match on both sides and you'll have two
accounts how old are you two
i'm 24 and my husband's 29. 20 that's so
awesome and you guys are already jumping
into this thing what are the options as
far as the 401k goes i know there's a 5
match is this traditional or is there a
roth option as well
i think it's just traditional um he's
still kind of ironing out the details
really we were the ones that brought it
to him and said look we kind of need to
either move on or start seeing if
there's some options here because
there's
kind of too many places that are
offering it right now to stick with
something that's not
and so they started working on it a
couple months ago and said that by
january they're hoping to have it all
set up
to get us going in it that's great so
this thing will kick off in january
yes it should kick off in january and
you've got your fully funded emergency
fund in place yes yep and all that paid
off way to go yeah if i'm in your shoes
here's what we recommend match is going
to beat roth which is going to be
traditional so i would go up to that 5
match for both of you out of your
paychecks and once you hit that i would
go uh if you don't already have a roth
ira go ahead and open one of those you
can get in touch with one of our smart
vester pros at ramseysolutions.com they
can walk you through that process
educate you on your options and that's
going to grow tax-free
with after tax dollars and so you can
put up to six thousand for people your
age you can put up to six thousand this
year and once you've done the match at
five percent you've got the six 000
fully funded roth iras for both of you
then you can go back to that company
401k and finish out your 15
okay that was what i was going to ask
was if we should put those that okay
yeah if they end up having a roth option
you could put that all in the roth
option the key here is we want that
tax-free growth to be working on our
behalf and you guys are so young you're
going to be multi-millionaires i'm just
so pumped hearing young people getting
into investing and doing it the right
way debt-free with an emergency fund
well thank you absolutely thank you so
much for the call good stuff there
marshall is in boise idaho marshall
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call how are you
i'm doing wonderful how can i help today
good i'm not quite as young as your last
caller i'm 44. okay yeah that's still
young man give yourself some credit
okay thanks
i'll try to remember that
just moved here from virginia and i kept
my house in virginia that i'm renting
out and then i'm renting an apartment
in boise in the boise area and i'm
trying to decide whether it's smart to
hold on to my house in virginia or not
i'm single uh one small dog
you got a single you're single and a dog
and you're renting right now are you
wanting to own a home in the boise area
are you there long term
don't know yet
but you're working in boise
currently i am and it's not
you're going you're going into the
office and all that you've got some
roots there
i i'm going in to teach children math
and uh i don't know how long i'll be
here but at least for the next year okay
well you know i don't i don't love the
idea of being a long-distance landlord
i'm sure you have you've got to have
something set up to where you know if
the hvac goes out you've got someone to
call right
yes i have a company who takes about 80
bucks a month to kind of manage things
okay
yeah long term i want to see you with
your with a primary residence paid off
and then getting into real estate
investing so if i'm in your shoes
personally what i would do is sell that
house take that money and if you think
you're going to plant roots in boise at
least for a few years you can go ahead
and find something in the boise area and
work aggressively to pay that off do you
have any other do you have any debt
currently
i've got about eight grand in student
loan debt and i've got about 25 in the
bank
for my emergency fund oh okay you have
25 in cash in the bank i thought you
meant you had debt i was like you have
debt in the bank how does that work okay
so we've got the eight grand of student
loans and then do you owe anything on
that property
i owe 110
and i could sell it tomorrow for
probably 220. oh
well that's a nice chunk of chain so
you'll you'll have about a hundred grand
if you sell it in cash
yep
well i want to see these still student
loans paid off i mean it's not a ton
here you could get rid of it without
having to sell the home so it's not a
there's no urgency there
but if i'm you i'm selling that house
taking a portion of that money getting
rid of these student loans you've
already got that emergency fund i would
even take down that emergency fund and
get rid of these student loans today
regardless of the home sale
okay what's making you happy is you're
nervous but what's what makes you
nervous about it
i just like having that that money in
the bank in case of an emergency
do you do you like paying your student
loan payment
uh i do not
well i guess you got to decide
well i haven't had to pay it in a while
but yeah i mean it's the next thing to
go i just wanted to maybe get up to
maybe around 30 grand in the bank before
i
paid that off well you'll still be in a
great financial spot even paying off
this loan you'll still have what 17
uh grand or so
16 grand so you're still going to be in
a great spot uh for an emergency fund's
sake i'm sure that's still at least a
few months worth of expenses but without
that payment you're gonna have a little
bit of income back in your life to put
towards your next goal which i assume
would be are you investing currently
um i
contribute to a 401k at work and have
been contributing to a 403b at my last
job for about 18 years
okay nice so i mean you're doing you're
doing some good things there's a slight
it's slightly out of order from what we
teach uh where i want you to pay off
that debt first you have the cash on
hand you can do that today and then you
can continue investing uh once you build
that emergency fund back up to where you
want it three to six month range i
assume since you're uh you're single you
want it closer to six months
yes okay yep
what were you saying so you think you
think get rid of that that house i would
personally because you don't have a
primary residence that's paid off if you
had a primary residence that's paid off
and this thing was still lingering
and it didn't bother you that much but
it's still a long distance situation and
you don't have a house that you're
living in and so i want to see you debt
free completely house and everything
before you get into uh real estate
investing so there's no there's nothing
on fire here but if i'm in your shoes
you're gonna put yourself in a really
sweet financial position when you have
six figures in cash and now you have
some options when you want to you know
go go put 20 down on a place in boise or
wherever you end up planting your roots
okay
well that helps and i appreciate your
time absolutely marshall thanks so much
for the call love this real estate talk
you know there's a lot of hype going on
in the real estate market today
particularly buyers out there think
they've got to buy and it's got to
happen right now and a lot of that is
because mortgage interest rates keep
reaching all-time lows making buyers
frantic to lock in and don't get me
wrong getting a low rate is a great
thing but it's not a green light to do
stupid stupid as in buying before you're
dead free or with zero down payment or
offering way over asking price and
waiving inspection stuff like that is
high risk and always costs you more than
you'd save in the long run
so get your head out of the craziness
for a second and look at your situation
are you debt free do you have a down
payment of 10 to 20 saved can you afford
home ownership do you want the
responsibility if and only if your
answer is a big fat yes to all of those
questions then buying a home is a smart
move for you now it's easy to get caught
up in all this home buying hype which is
why you need fax we've got a great free
mortgage calculator to figure out
exactly what you can actually afford
with the mortgage options out there just
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
free tools to check out that free
mortgage calculator do things the smart
way this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and 6 gigs
of data with no contract the average
family saves over 70 dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
i'm george campbell ramsey personality
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast both great podcasts
you can find on the ramsay network
you're listening to the ramsay show it's
a free call this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i would be
happy and honored to answer your money
questions joey joins us in fort myers
florida joey welcome to the ramsay show
thank you thank you um so i have a
question so i am all cut off on my stuff
i do have a car payment for the next two
months zero percent interest no issues
it's like a thousand dollars um but i do
have 120 000 in the bank right now i
have a potential additional 120 to 130
000 in the bank if i need it um and i'm
currently in an apartment for the next
four months
and i'm trying to figure out what should
i do i want to invest in real estate
potentially it sounds great on facebook
a lot of benefits but i still need to
become more educated around it
um but you know i was thinking of
instead of buying a single family home
buying a new price or or a quadplex
um but but really i'm kind of just in
the ether at this point with all the
options but no options at the same time
because i'm not that educated on it so
i'd love some advice how old are you
i'm 33 33 about my age all right and
what's your income
uh
it's 105 000 a year fantastic
and tell me this where is all this money
coming from that you've got in the bank
have you just been saving for a few
years now yeah yeah yeah i uh i have a
pretty good job um obviously and uh just
been saving um and and being a little
frugal so yeah
very impressive and you said you have
potentially another 120 in the bank what
does that mean
um so i so i had a i put the house
and had an addition made a hundred
thousand off of it um and i gave it to
my mom because she helped me buy the
house um but she is uh she's demanding
that i take it back but i i want it to
be hers because it's kind of my payback
for her so um if i need it i have it so
you gifted this thing to her and she's
like no take this back i don't want it
basically yeah interesting well that's
nice of you so you're not
brand new to this real estate game
since you flipped a house
well here's the thing you mentioned at
the beginning that you have this car
loan and you mentioned that it's zero
percent so you're not worried about it
what is this car loan how much
uh it's only 800 bucks left 800 to 900
and i could pay it off tomorrow you owe
900 total on this car debt
yeah yeah and you have a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in the bank
correct is this sentimental what's going
why don't you just pay the car off today
it's just i just oh if it's zero percent
of
this is stupid to carry around a debt
when you have 120 000 it's a math
equation
yeah yeah i i see that do you have any
other payments in your life is this your
only debt you have
that's it yep other than my rent payment
yep wow i mean you've done really well
man i don't know what's making you hang
on to to payments but i think you need
to say no to payments for the rest of
your life and become extra wealthy i
mean you're doing so great otherwise
yeah so so should i what should i get
into to potentially you know to grow
that that money
um should it be in rental properties um
what are your thoughts clearly that's
something you're passionate about and so
what i want you to do is once you pay
off the car today which you're going to
do as soon as we're off the phone
get rid of that debt and then i want you
to park some of that money for a fully
funded emergency fund you already have
it in cash so figure out what one
month's expenses looks like for you and
are you single
i am okay i would probably lean towards
that six months since you already have
in cash so take one months of actual
expenses not income multiply that out by
six and leave that in maybe a high yield
savings account and and park it there
for emergencies
okay then whatever money's left after
that are you currently investing into
retirement
uh i am yeah
okay uh i'm gonna let you continue doing
that because this is all going to be
solved in a matter of hours so i'm not
going to tell you to pause investing
because you're about to pay this car off
you already have the money for your
emergency fund so are you investing 15
into
uh something like a 401k at work
uh i am not actually what are you
investing in
um not well i'm doing 401k but not 15
um
i've
seen the returns um and then kind of
kind of some of my side hustles i was
deciding to spend that money on some of
those side hustles which um
yeah
okay
well uh here's here's what what i
recommend what we teach is to do 15 and
you can do it if you've got a match at
work do it up to the match and then you
can open up a roth ira and fill that up
the max is 6000 for you and then go back
to the 401k and keep filling that out if
you don't have a roth option
once you do 15
then you're on to baby steps 5 and 6
which is saving for kids college do you
have kids
i do not no kids so you're moving on to
paying off your house early um which
you've got a property already that's
paid for
no i'm i'm literally renting in an
apartment but the one your mom is in
oh yeah
we pay that off okay so i think your
next goal is to find a primary residence
for you to live in and pay that off i
wouldn't go getting into real estate
investing quite yet
okay
so uh you're in the fort myers area i
would start looking at what houses cost
over there if that's where you're
planting roots and say all right if i
wanted 20 or more down i mean a guy like
you it wouldn't shock me if you were
able to pay cash for a house
with with your income and your diligence
with saving but i'm not going to be mad
at you if you can put 20 down and avoid
pmi that private mortgage insurance
that's going to avoid you throwing money
away to protect the banks
and so once you do that and you pay off
your house early then we can start
talking about real estate investing
um as you live and give like no one else
in baby step seven so that's where that
would fall i'm all for real estate
investing i think it's fantastic i think
you're going to do really well with it
but there's a time and a place for it
and you're you're real close but you've
got a few things to do before that
okay
absolutely i appreciate it yeah man way
to go love hearing stories like that
joey pay that car off buddy all right
amber joins us in little rock arkansas
amber welcome to the ramsay show
hey george i'm so excited to talk to you
well it's nice that someone's excited to
talk to me for for once it's great to
talk to you amber how can i help
um we are in baby step two okay and i
just have a question about
um our emergency fund and how we're
doing on it um
i have four children
and four small dogs wow busy
yes very busy a lot of creatures a lot
of drool
and our dogs are
you know like our children to us you
know they sleep in bed with us they're
our babies as well
um i'm not comfortable
only a thousand dollar emergency fund
in case they need to go to the vet if
there's an emergency
so you're more concerned about the dogs
than the kids
yeah
what if a kid breaks a leg
amber this is a hilarious scenario here
you're more concerned about the dog vet
bill than you are the kids medical bills
um well luckily they we have very good
insurance okay so i
i hardly pay anything they have uh two
different coverages okay okay this makes
a lot more sense for them
that's completely free if any children
need to go to the doctor i don't pay
anything but yeah i do pay um like one
of my dogs hurt their leg and i had to
pay four thousand dollars bless you get
sick oh my gosh
okay so this makes me nervous only
having a thousand dollars i understand
so how much debt do you have
um
total of thirty thousand okay what's the
household income
um
my husband makes six thousand and then i
get
to yes
i get
2 000 child support and also 800 of a
retirement so like 8 800 total okay and
that's take home
yes so we can get rid of this debt
within a matter of months and get you a
lot more security with a fully funded
emergency fund
yeah we have about um 3 000 a month we
can put towards the debt
okay so that's 10 months i think you can
do it faster than that i think you can
live on less than that and here's the
deal uh i get that a thousand dollars is
scary but i want you to be scared
because debt is scary it's stealing from
your paycheck it's stealing from your
life and so you've got to make a
decision to go i want to take this
uncomfortability and let it fuel me in
my baby step two journey as i pay off my
debt using the debt snowball from
smallest to largest regardless of
interest rate and in no time you're
going to build that fully funded
emergency fund but right now you've got
to let this fuel you on your journey to
debt freedom this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm george campbell ramsay personality
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast on the ramsey network
and it's a free call this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you need some advice you want some
affirmation you want a second opinion i
am here for you today today is the day
you can actually get on the show don't
be scared don't be shy especially you
millennials you gen ziggers who think
your phones are just for tick tocks no
they make phone calls too there's a
special app for it and if you just type
in the numbers triple eight eight two
five five two two five you'll get
connected with kelly and she will be
mostly happy to talk with you and
hopefully we can get you on the air and
get you some help that is what i'm here
for we just took a call from amber
and it was hilarious she's got four kids
and four dogs and she was more concerned
about the dogs understandably so because
the kids have health insurance but she
was worried about the thousand dollar
emergency fund and it reminded me of
this hilarious article i found from
yahoo life
survey says nearly half of millennials
and gen zers spend money on their pets
social media
this is wild new survey from lending
tree more than one quarter of the 14 25
pet owners polled so 1400 pet owners
were pulled 28
said they've spent money on their pets
for social media posts
oh my gosh
about 47 percent of gen zers admitted to
the practice along with 40
of millennials and here's the wild part
when you dig into the numbers the gen z
or say they spent the most an average
of
hundred dollars per month on their dogs
a mix of essentials subscription boxes
pet insurance and the expenses required
for social media fame
y'all if there was a wall i would try to
punch through it right now i don't know
that i'd even make it through the
drywall but this is insane
what are we doing now unless your dog
makes you money
like i'm a big fan of doug the pug and
doug the pug is a multi-millionaire and
i am not so doug the pug is doing
something right but if you're aspiring
to get a pet sponsorship uh and all
these things but you're spending almost
two grand a month to make this happen
this is insane
and then you're telling me uh that the
housing market's too expensive yeah it
is when you're spending two grand a
month on your dog
goodness gracious how cute is your
pomeranian
i have an adorable french bulldog and
yes she does have an instagram but we
rarely post we just did it to stop
bothering people on our own personal
social media feeds and now we don't
spend anywhere near two grand a month on
our french bulldog as expensive as they
are kelly's looking at me with a lot of
judgment right now and i'm i am here for
it i am loving it
so there you go that's
that's some news from yahoo life thank
you for that amazing survey from
lendingtree let's go to the phones we've
got heather in dallas texas heather
welcome to the ramsay show
i'm so glad to talk to you thank you for
taking my call absolutely how can i help
today um so my question is i discovered
y'all um about a year and a half ago
well not quite right after i had bought
a new home so i bought a home about 14
months ago
and then discovered all and i'm thinking
i may be a little house poor and i'm
wondering if i should sell and if so
with what sense of urgency in the
current market okay all right walk me
through the situation so uh what's your
household income
it's right at 95 growth all right and is
that just you is there other people
involved here just me fantastic okay and
uh what was this house purchase how much
so i bought it for 340 000. i put 80 000
down so i financed um 260. okay um
unfortunately for 30 years
at 3 percent and i owe about 256 now
i
talked to my realtor recently and he
said he could probably sell it for 4.35
whoa
i know thank you pandemic i guess it's
the one from my decent thing yeah that's
impressive
so
i i love the home it's everything i
would want but um i'm just wondering
if i if i should go
well uh i don't want you to think you're
in a fire now what percentage of your
take-home pay is the mortgage payment
i'm thinking if i did my math correctly
it's about 31
okay i mean we recommend 25 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fix so
obviously you went with a 30 year that
lowers your payment and so
it is a little bit high do you think
your income is going to increase in the
near future
um not by much probably like three
percent per year is my guess two to
three percent average
okay
and do you have a debt free do you have
you don't have any debt other than the
house right and you have a fully funded
emergency fund i have a fully funded
three months since i'm single i am
shooting to the six months but i have
three months so far
okay other than that i'm like on step
six i believe yeah well heather you're
based on the numbers here you're not in
in terrible financial shape i mean is
the payment stressing you out is it
putting a big crunch on the budget
no i'm just um i'm just totally getting
on board with y'all and i just want to
do the right thing so you went oh my
gosh this ramsay plan i didn't do it the
right way oh my gosh no
and i do like to have a little bit just
cash flow you know i wouldn't mind
having more just to be more generous or
whatever the case may be but i just
didn't know what sense of urgency i
should feel right now no i mean
nothing's on fire if you called and said
hey it's 50 or more of my take-home pay
and i'm just
riddled with anxiety and i don't sleep
at night and i can't do anything with my
life because of this mortgage payment i
would say yes sell it but you told me
this is basically your dream house you
love it um you're in this location for a
while i wouldn't i wouldn't go selling
it today now if there was any other
reason to sell down the line
i would say okay go for it but if you
have no reason to sell other than you
think you're under water in this thing
you're not based on the numbers okay
good so and hopefully the market it
won't decrease in value very
anytime soon no i think it'll cool down
eventually i don't think it's you're
gonna lose a hundred thousand dollars on
this deal it may not be 435 forever but
maybe in five years it is back to 435
and you still live there so i would
still be aggressively paying this thing
down and later down the road if i'm you
i'm gonna refinance and you can do the
math to see when the break-even point
would be um on that but i would
refinance eventually to a 15 or you can
just pay it down i mean it's at three
percent you've got a pretty low interest
rate there so treat this thing like a
10-15 year mortgage and get this thing
out of your life so that you can move on
to bigger and better goals
well thank you that puts my mind at ease
a little bit that's what i'm here for i
love to hear it that's so great heather
thank you so much for the call good to
talk with you we've got mitch in pueblo
colorado mitch welcome to the ramsay
show
hi good afternoon good afternoon
hey
so i've got a situation where i have an
opportunity to
purchase uh
half of what my brother owns on the
property we're in on together okay and
use it as a
rental property okay
okay he wants to sell and he wants his
half so he can invest in something else
i'm thinking more long term
and want to leave something for the kids
you know further on down the line
uh problem is i don't have cash
to buy him out
so i would need to yeah i would need to
borrow
uh
70 well 65 grand
do you have a mortgage currently
yes we do oh boy
well this puts you in a bit of a nickel
here
so what happens if you don't have the
cash what happens with you with your
half
well uh
i'm going to try to convince him to
for both of us to use it as a rental
okay for now but he's saying he wants to
get rid of it he wants to sell it and
take the money
take his half yes he wants his cash
correct so i have to try to convince him
to use it as a rental until
i can come up with half of what the
property is valued at so i can purchase
his house i mean this is right it's
basically you're wanting to get into
real estate investing right now but you
don't really have the cash flow to do so
that is absolutely right do you have any
debt other than your personal mortgage
no none whatsoever what's your mortgage
what's left on it
uh 105. 105 000 and what's your
household income
uh at this moment in time
it's a little less than 70. 70. not much
yeah well what i would do if i'm in your
shoes i'm trying to pay off this
mortgage before i jump into real estate
investing and that might be a
conversation i mean it's family so you
know it could get dicey but hopefully
he'll be willing to work with you and go
hey can we rent this thing out for three
years let me try to get this house paid
off and and work up this cash and over
time maybe you guys can work out a deal
but i do not like the idea of you
borrowing money while you still have a
mortgage getting into this thing having
this anxiety in your life and trying to
pay both of these mortgages essentially
with the hopes of of cashing out a
little bit or making some rental income
so no i don't like the idea of you
borrowing money i think it's going to be
a hard conversation with your brother to
figure the situation out but please for
the love of god don't borrow money when
you still have got a mortgage man
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books my thanks to ben hill our
producer kelly daniel associate producer
and phone screener and you america for
tuning in and calling in triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number we'll be back with you before you
know it this is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm george campbell your host
flying solo today and it's a free call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you wanna hear more from me uh
the the few of you that may want to you
can find me on the fine print and on
trade leadership podcasts both podcasts
you can find on the ramsey network or
wherever great podcasts are found
open phones this hour and we are kicking
it off with jesus in el paso el paso
what's up jesus how's it going
okay good and you man how you doing i'm
doing great how can i help today
okay so i have a question
so we were me and my wife were working
on the baby steps
and we paid off 24 000 in six months in
you know car payments that we had and
everything nice way to go man
so the only debt i have right now is my
mortgage which i owe
99 99k okay
now i've been thinking as soon as i got
out of high school i started to work i
never went to college or anything
straight to the workforce
yes sir so i've been thinking about
going back to technical school
for a 19-month period
okay
just wanted to you know some advice on
whether it's a good idea or this would
be paid with student loans oh boy well
that changes things for me i mean i love
the idea of you going to tech school and
getting an education uh but i don't
think you need to do it with student
loans is there an urgency around you
going to tech school
no it's just that uh
you know it just came to mind you know
to
because
it's for hvac that i want to go to
school for it yeah what are you doing
now for your career
i'm an automotive technician i do
service for all the automotive
dealerships in
el paso very cool what's your household
income
45k a year okay and it's just you
uh yes i'm the only one working okay so
we got 45k a year but you're debt free
except for the mortgage do you have a
fully funded emergency fund
yes
all right and are you investing 15
of your household income currently
no
well at the moment
how old are you
27 okay so you're nice and young that
makes me feel better i want you to get
investing and i want you to cash flow
this tech school how much does this tech
school cost for this 19 months
25k
25k and have you done your research as
far as uh schools in the area online
programs all of the options for this
hvac program
yes this is the one that i i i liked
everything they offered
and i and i've had uh buddies of mine
that have gone there and
they they always recommend that school
and they had a good experience
yes okay
is there any way to get your income up
is there a way that your your wife could
work or you could take on a side job to
get a bigger shovel
well the thing is that i work from seven
in the morning to sometimes seven at
night eight at night
you're working twelve hour days
yeah times yes man
is there another uh job in this field
currently that you could jump over to
and make more money
right now that's the reason i wanted to
move to hvac because i i'm pretty much
stuck
from apprentice
technicians and and the
sales reps which
the sales reps are all taking up all the
positions and those guys aren't going
nowhere yeah well i want you to explore
your options for another job that's in
the field you're in currently so that
you can get a bigger shovel so that you
can cash flow the college experience and
get to this tech school because 25k i
mean it's not a small amount of money
compared to your income
but you don't have any debt and so any
extra money you could be using to save
up for that and because there's no real
urgency other than hey i want to switch
into this field you could wait another
year to go to tech school there's
nothing driving you to go tomorrow right
right
okay i mean be looking for any kind of
scholarships that might be available
grants talk to the school talk to the
guidance counselors
i want you to really do some some deep
research here and do some deep work to
figure out all of the options i don't
want you to just go well i'm out of
options i gotta take out student loans
guess i'm gonna do that especially when
there's no urgency around this
yes other than hey i'm not super happy
with what i'm doing now uh but i love
your passion for for going into the hvac
field i think that's fantastic i'm a big
proponent of the trades but i don't want
you to fall into the 45 million
americans with 1.6 trillion dollars in
student loan debt i don't want you added
to that stat
okay so i would talk to your wife and
figure out a plan uh to where you guys
can cash flow this experience and
whenever you have the money is when you
can do it you're going to move at the
speed of cash here uh that is the best
game plan
and if you aren't strapped with student
loan payments america the odds are you
know someone who is this is a hot topic
and millions of people are putting their
lives on hold
they can't buy a house or have kids
because they are stuck or even worse
they're waiting and waiting and waiting
for the government to save them with
student loan forgiveness what a joke
have you seen the stats on this thing
public service loan forgiveness program
two percent that's the amount of people
who actually had their loans forgiven
out of everyone who applied two percent
i'm not taking those chances you're
better off in vegas at this point
our team produced a brand new feature
length film documentary called borrowed
future it launched last week it was on
all the charts on amazon google play
apple tv all the places and it's out now
you can go watch this thing
and it's 88 minutes long and it's
something that you can show to your kids
to your friends your family
have a party get some popcorn it's
riveting it uncovers the dark side of
the student loan industry is there a
bright side i don't know but we uncover
the dark side and it exposes how the
system is built to work against you
you'll see dave ramsey weigh in on the
epic failure otherwise known as the
student loan program along with featured
interviews from industry insiders and
thought leaders like seth godin seth
frotman and dr john deloney
we're coming hard at this folks we're
swinging at the student loan problem
with the goal to arm parents and
students across the country with the
truth and here it is
you do not have to take out loans to get
a college education
hey zeus doesn't have to do it and you
don't either
you can be a student without a student
loan it's possible you can graduate
debt-free and avoid the predatory
student loan industry and we feature all
kinds of inspiring stories heartbreaking
stories in this documentary you've got
to go watch this thing
it's just a few bucks to rent and i
promise you it's it's the price of your
latte so skip one latte and go watch
borrowed future you can watch it on
apple tv amazon prime video google play
or you can watch it from our website
borrowed future
dot com and the stats on this are
mind-blowing america's student loan debt
has grown from 240 billion
to 1.58 trillion
since 2003.
one in four u.s households have student
loan debt with the average borrower
carrying 38
792 dollars
y'all this
is the biggest crisis that my generation
has to face
and you can get out you don't have to
wait for forgiveness you don't have to
pay it off for 20 years you can do this
thing
but you've got to be aware of the traps
you've got to be willing to change and
make some sacrifices to get rid of the
student loan debt once and forever sally
mae is not your friend
navient is not your friend make a
decision to change your legacy and
change the way you handle your money
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print podcast and entree
leadership podcast
open phones this hour the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five call me with your money
question i would be happy to take it and
reggie did that in chattanooga tennessee
reggie welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for taking my call though
george absolutely have a good question
i would like to know what will be the
best way to invest ten thousand dollars
so that it's liquid so that it's
accessible
for things like purchasing a car
and and for me
home improvements you know renovating a
home being able to have access to it but
it makes enough money that i can do
those things so you want your money to
make money
yes sir i love that well you have you
have two conflicting words here invest
in liquid
and when i hear liquid it makes me think
i would not invest that now if this is a
long-term goal we're talking five years
out
and you want it to be liquid sure you
could invest that in you know just a
normal brokerage account outside of
retirement and some mutual funds or
index funds and have that money grow for
you but it sounds like these these
short-term goals of yours this is less
than five years on the horizon correct
yes
okay
at that point i know it's not fun it's
not that sexy but i would park that in a
high-yield savings account which right
now will get you about a half a percent
okay how you'll save this
is that disappointing to hear a half a
percent
oh yes
here's here's the good news if you
invest that money you might lose 5 or 10
or 15 percent
you tracking with me reggie what i want
here is to keep your money safe
so it's going to grow at a very small
rate but right now i would not be
throwing this money into the market when
it could become 5k instead of 10
if you need this thing six months from
now
what if i just want to wait for a year
hold it for a year and see what it has
done for me and then do
the time horizon on that is still too
short where you're going to see it's too
much of a roller coaster when you look
at the market on the long term it it's a
steadier incline but when you look at
the short term man it is a roller
coaster and that money is going to get
jostled around and if you need that
thing and in under you know it within
that under three year time frame i just
think it's real dicey to be investing
that money
i mean it's not going to turn into 20k
we're not going to go investing in you
know some hot cryptocurrency and hope
for the best year that we don't want to
gamble this money away you've worked
hard for this money and so the thing
that you can do is protect it uh so i
would if i'm you i'm putting in a high
yield savings account do you currently
have any debt
no no debt no debt and you have a fully
funded emergency fund
fully funded yes all right and you're
investing 15
into retirement
yes okay you're on track reg you're
doing great how old are you
54.
54 years old fantastic
and uh what are those short-term goal
goals that you mentioned you said house
repairs and what else
uh home improvements you know the house
is a little dated you want to like
improve it and add on
to rental so add-on
garage
and uh make room for purchase of a
new vehicle instead of
buying another unit right well always
saying pay cash pay cash pay cash yeah i
would still pay cash are you a
millionaire
not yet okay i'm on my way until you're
there i wouldn't be buying a brand new
car now you said new car that may just
mean upgrading to a nicer slightly used
car but i want you paying cash for that
and these home repairs instead of hoping
your money grows in that high yield
savings account just start a sinking
fund start saving up every single month
you have no debt and so you can just
throw you know a few hundred bucks a
month into that high yield savings
account and watch it grow at that half a
percent but i think you've got this
you're not i would not recommend
throwing this money into the market when
you're gonna need it six months a year
from now thanks for the call jackie
joins us in san antonio jackie welcome
to the ramsay show
hey um thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can i help
hey um i have a question we are working
on our debt snowball we have about 23
000 left on our regular snowball and
then i kind of have our whatever i have
in collection separate
um to pay once we're done with our
regular snowball
and i've gotten served and i have a
judgment against me for one of the
collections and my question is should i
pay that off first
and then continue working on our
snowball or should i just let them hang
out until i get to them
what kind of debt is this in collections
it's a credit card
okay how much debt
um the balance on the account is 50 200
and i've called them before to try and
settle and the lowest they would offer
me was 3 600 and i just didn't have that
at the time i could probably settle for
that amount now
um but i would obviously want to
negotiate a little bit lower if i could
i would uh yeah i mean you can try to
negotiate lower and if they give you a
lower number i would just pay that
settlement in full and then continue on
with the debt snowball i don't like that
there's a judgment in my life i don't
like them yeah this is i mean i feel
anxiety and it's not even my debt and
collection
yeah and the rest of the debt snowball
what's the other kind of debt
um all credit cards pretty much in a car
okay we've been on a spending spree this
has been fun well a little bit it's it's
been a journey that's for sure but now
there's a judgment so it got a lot less
fun
yeah you gotta pay the piper okay so
yeah i would i would go ahead and uh
negotiate with them if they can but
really i mean it's the debt is the debt
and if they're unwilling to budge uh i
wouldn't push it too much further i want
to i want to get this out of my life do
you have a 3600 on hand
um
kind of yes uh we refinanced our house
so i have a refund on our escrow account
that's coming back so i will have that
money okay well make sure your four
walls are taken care of it sounds like
you're doing okay in that category
right you've got food on the table
utilities are being paid all that stuff
yes okay yeah i would get this
collections mess cleaned up because of
the judgment involved here and it's a
little bit of a fire and i want to put
this fire out and then continue on with
my life with the traditional debt
snowball
awesome
thanks so much for the call appreciate
it let's move to chris in winston-salem
north carolina chris welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call
i
i have a question i have uh about a
hundred thousand in a mutual fund uh
no debt with this section to the
mortgage
which is about
000
and so i was wondering if
you think i should
apply that mutual fund to
the mortgage and try to start getting
that
mortgage taken care of and out of the
way
okay so we're completely
debt-free outside of the mortgage the
mortgage is 130 000 and you have a
hundred thousand in mutual funds is this
just non-retirement just in a general
brokerage account
yes it's just a general broker's account
yeah i'm cashing that thing out and
slapping on the mortgage have you ever
had uh have you ever had any point in
your life where you didn't have a
mortgage just completely debt-free
paid for it
i have not
how would it feel to not have to pay
that mortgage ever again uh
yes i've been dreaming about it so
i would love to see that i would love to
see it too how old are you chris
47 47
and you're real close to having a paid
off house man that would be nice i love
it i can i hear it in your voice i'm
excited for you yeah i don't i would
cash out this mutual fund uh we always
tell people if it's in retirement don't
touch it but you just have this outside
of retirement and so this is liquid
money that you could use today to pay
down this mortgage and you can get to
investing later you're gonna have plenty
of time to invest
okay okay well great great i appreciate
that man you are crushing it chris a
hundred thousand dollars in liquid cash
and he'll he'll be down to 30 000 on
that mortgage and uh get rid of that
thing in no time hey call us up when
you're when you're completely debt free
or come to a debt-free scream i'd love
to hear that story what an incredible
guy
guys a lot of fun calls on the show
today a lot a lot of mix we've got a lot
of house housing questions a lot of
people moving around they're maybe
starting to rethink some things due to
the pandemic or the great resignation
going hey i live here but i don't have
to live here should i move hey i want to
go back to school should i take on the
student loans
i have a budgeting problem i've got a
debt problem these are all things that i
love to help people with so call me up
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm george campbell ramsay personality
flying solo today on the ramsey show
give me a call triple eight eight two
five
five two two five
you know i love going out during the
breaks of the show and meeting our
amazing guests who travel from all over
the country to see the headquarters to
hang out a lot of people come to
celebrate where they've where they've
come on their money journey so i want to
encourage you guys we are just south of
nashville tennessee it's a great trip
and whoever's hosting the show that day
they're all waving look at them on the
screen there if you're watching uh and
it's a great time we'll give you a free
ramsay show mug we'll load you up with
uh free coffee free baked goods and
cookies you can get your your picture
made all that fun stuff we've got a
little museum uh back there a hallway
where you can walk and see the history
of this place and the team did an
incredible job with the whole experience
so come down make a trip of it a lot of
families do that they'll make it a pit
stop on the road trip and our team is
very friendly and they'll be happy to
host you you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and schedule your
visit we'll let you know what's going on
that day and make sure we are ready for
your arrival
all right let's go to the phone lines
this hour elizabeth is in las vegas
nevada elizabeth welcome to the ramsay
show
hi thank you so much for having me sure
how can i help
um so um i'm currently on baby steps six
my husband and i and um
we're in the process of making sure that
we are putting money towards our
retirement i currently have about 250k
um prior to the marriage and um
my husband has always said that he has
money within this family trust but he
has no control over it and he sees that
as part of our retirement savings
um and i'm trying to find
a good way to
kind of persuade him to understand
um in like a loving way that um if we
have no control over it then that means
that we can't plan for our future with
that money if it comes to us later on
down the line extra money great but
right now we need to
kind of follow and stick to a plan with
that not being in mind
yeah any suggestions i'm with you on
that one uh how much has does he have
saved in retirement
um
for probably maybe 2000 currently um he
transitioned from a new job
into a role here in the u.s and so this
is all new to him
oh okay so he's new to investing in
general
investing in general correct it's all
been kind of controlled by the family
his dad passed away and left the money
and
they all just sort of decided to leave
it to the mom to do everything i said
there's nothing legally in that regards
in his name even
whoa so mom can just say hey i'm not
giving you a dime of this
in theory yes yeah oh boy we trust him
but in theory yes
yeah but there's no there's no legal
things going on here where he's gonna
get a hundred thousand dollars when he
turns a certain age there's none of that
it's not no it's not considered like
that it's more of a retirement that the
three siblings have with the mom
so what's the agreement that what's the
agreement with this trust when does he
get the speech
it's
in theory they each of them can pull out
money when they want we've had it in
this move where one of the siblings had
talked about it and then they all came
to a consensus and decided that wasn't a
good idea so they that particular
sibling didn't
um
so
you know i believe in the family they're
fantastic they're super lovingly it's
not an issue of not testing them it's
just that we have no control over it i
don't even know what how much is in
there what it's accruing
anything like that so
in that regards my husband's like well i
don't want to pull the money out so
again in my eyes it just i see it as
down the line if we get it great but
currently we have to just focus on what
we are doing
with the money that we have control over
absolutely so how old are you two
um i'm 33 and he's 46.
okay so you guys are way off from
retirement um i would continue investing
15 of your household income into
retirement uh are you guys debt free
um other than the mortgage and i think
we'll be able to pay that off in about
two years
we have an apartment um
overseas that we're looking to probably
sell but i think it'll take about six
months before we even start that process
okay well that puts you guys in a good
position to you know build wealth and
give generously when you're in baby step
seven there so i'm not as worried as far
as your retirement but i do want him to
understand that if it's out of his
control then we can't include that now
the day that he pulls the money out and
it's in your bank account and in your
investments then we can say okay this is
part of our retirement so i'm with you
on that i think you're you may need some
outside
third party opinions on this so i if i'm
you i'm gonna contact a smart vester pro
in your area these are investing pros
that can walk you guys through your
situation
and go all right here's what i'm seeing
for your retirement plan are you on
track based on all the factors involved
that are in your control so that's what
i would do because when you're hearing
it from an investment professional
versus you know just his wife it may
come across differently
yeah because i think it comes across as
maybe i know better or that i'm trying
to be controlling and i think you're
right i think coming i can coming from
somebody who's quote unquote an expert
it comes across better and maybe he
would listen yeah i don't want this to
cause a rift in in the marriage so you
can jump on ramsay solutions.com and
click on trusted pros get in touch with
an investing pro in the vegas area it'll
show you you know five options there
when you enter your information and sit
down with them and then just lay out all
the information you laid out with me and
they can get you on a path and go hey
here's here's what you're on track to do
is this good enough is this what you
know does this line up with your goals
and uh i think you're you're right here
but i don't want this to make this an
argument of who's right and who's wrong
and i know that's not your heart behind
this either so
get with a smart investor pro and have
them lay it out for him and hopefully
that changes his mind but
he's not in control of the money and so
therefore i'm not counting it it's icing
on the cake if he does get it down the
line thanks for the call
matthew is in jackson mississippi
matthew welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for having me absolutely how can
i help
so uh i am a pastor and as a pastor i
live in a church-owned personage and so
we are looking to save eventually for a
house possibly
may get closer to retirement which is
going to be probably 25 30 years down
the road
and our current plan had been to use
contributions to a roth ira
uh to
put towards that eventual
down payment and hoping to pay it off to
you know buy it in cash completely
and wanted to get your opinion about
that
um i had spoken to we have a financial
advisor uh firm that
uh is available to us through the united
methodist church i'm a methodist pastor
and so they had
uh
suggested to us that instead of
contributing toward a roth
for
the house
but instead piling all that we could
into our 403b that we have that i have
through the conference
and then using
um
so saving and tax saving and then also
we're able to
make a loan of half of the amount that
we contribute
at the point that we buy the house and
that was their way of uh of saving
towards the house
uh so i just want to get another opinion
about you know which idea is better
uh
in what we're looking at
so if i'm hearing you correctly your
financial advisor said to dump it in the
403 b and then take a 403b loan out to
get the house
yes
yes
the reason behind it was you save taxes
on the front end and you're paying
yourself back with the loan
and
my thought is if we put it in the roth
because i know we can use the roth to
help buy the house and make either a
huge down payment or pay paid off
completely and it's you know we can do
it early if we end up finding ourselves
in a situation
uh where we need a house prior to
retirement you know if i move to a
church that doesn't have a personage and
yeah i need to purchase a house uh and
so it kind of conflicts with what he was
saying and so i want to get another
perspective on that i
i don't see the benefit in doing this i
i mean i don't understand the full tax
benefits of what he's saying but taking
out a loan when you have the cash to pay
for a house is asinine and so i think
you might need a new financial advisor
uh i would get in touch with one of our
smarvester pros what i would tell you to
do is to park this money into some good
mutual funds uh just in a brokerage
account outside of retirement i don't
want you using your retirement money to
purchase the house you're going to
unplug all that growth that you're going
to need to live on for the rest of your
life so that's what i would do if i'm in
your shoes and to get that process
started get in touch with one of our
smartmaster pros at ramseysolutions.com
and they can help you do things the
ramsey way without debt you don't need
to take on a loan man you're going to
save up and pay for the same cash we're
talking 25 30 years from now and you're
following the ramsay plan you got this
don't listen to your financial advisor
get a new one this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast flying solo today taking your
calls the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's talk
money call me up micah is in dayton ohio
micah welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks for having me absolutely how
can i help today
um i've just got a question um i'm
relatively new to listening to you guys
so i'm still kind of learning the baby
steps and things of that nature but i
also got a suggestion um with my life
insurance i currently have term life
insurance my wife and i both do and
i was advised for my financial advisor
to go ahead and swap over the whole life
which was going to be like 220 a month
versus i think will paying like 34 right
now for the term insurance and it would
basically be
i think the same dollar amount of
coverage but i would have the death
benefit passed you know where i guess my
whole life and
but it just seems to me like it's a lot
of money to
to put on the month but i also i think i
heard that you guys don't really think
that would be a wise decision i was kind
of wondering why i'm just really
completely new to all this yeah well i
appreciate the call if you could see my
face i was almost laughing uh and i have
a very honest question for you if you if
you know the answer does your financial
advisor sell whole life insurance
yes also a concern ding ding ding we
have our answer
okay so let's do let's do some quick
math here
what do you think your financial advisor
is going to make more money on your term
life insurance that's about the cost of
a pizza or is he going to make more
commissions off of a 220
a month premium
uh definitely the 220
and he even said that the first two or
three years would go toward
basically paying from what i understand
paying him and whoever was a part of
that back and then it would turn into
like a savings plan which is kind of
what he was pitching as far as for me to
the reason for me to do it yeah oh i bet
and i bet he sees dollar signs sparkling
in the in his future if he can get you
to switch over um you need to get a new
financial advisor today
okay you need to find someone with the
heart of a teacher who's not out to make
a buck off of you but is going to help
you do things the ramsey way and help
you uh make smart decisions with your
financial future and i can tell you why
we don't recommend whole life but that's
a whole nother discussion from the fact
that this guy is trying to make more
commission off of you that's it
you really think it's i mean he told me
that like he thinks that i have a good
short term and a good long term as far
as my savings in retirement and his what
he said was he wanted me to have like
kind of a medium ground like 5 10 15
years from now if i need something to
draw from
but i mean i was kind of thinking why
don't i just do that through a normal
savings account like i don't really
understand what the benefit was so that
kind of makes sense but it was possibly
yeah this guy is trying to screw you and
here's why whole life really sucks it's
a lot more expensive which you already
know
it's trying to do two financial jobs at
once it's trying to be insurance and
it's trying to be an investing vehicle
and it ends up doing neither thing very
well it delays or stops you from ever
becoming self-insured which is why we
teach you to get term life insurance and
once it runs out you're in a place
financially where you don't need it and
it can lead to having a huge amount of
your cash value in the policy disappear
if you die without cashing it out
that sucks sure
yeah so i would jump onto
ramseysolutions.com and get in touch
with a smartvestor pro
who can lead you to much better
financial decisions because this guy is
out to make a commission and that tells
me that he doesn't have the heart of a
teacher i'm sure he's a he's a fine
person but he's a terrible financial
advisor he's just trying to make money
off a little bit
yeah that's what kind of stinks like i
really do look like he seems like a good
guy but i know that's probably part of
the job too
yeah well he's less of a good guy now in
my book uh but you can still be friends
with him but i would not let i wouldn't
take financial advice from this dude i
would get in touch with a smartvestor
pro uh who has the heart of a teacher
who's gonna show you what you're doing
and why and they're gonna do things the
ramsey way and what we teach is to get
that term life 15 to 20 years level uh
that's 10 to 12 times your income for
each of you which it sounds like you've
got good term life in place you're doing
the right things stay on track do not
listen to this buffoon thanks for the
call josh is in tampa florida josh
welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can i help you
yeah so my wife and i of 10 years um
we've been going through counseling and
we've been trying to save our marriage
but
we decided um it was best that we get a
divorce at the end of this year i'm
sorry to hear that so
yeah um yeah we
we tried a lot and
now i'm really just kind of looking
forward and seeing
you know what would you guys do if you
woke up in my shoes so
um i have a i have some cash saved
and there will be additional cash once
we sell our home
that we own together in equity
so that'll be a approximately 180 000
so my my question is if you woke up in
my shoes and you had 180 000
um
what would you
what would you do i'm kind of torn
between trying to buy a house cash
and or trying to
invest in more passive income
whether that be real estate or
a business venture
well josh um i'm trying to just make the
best decision yeah
i totally understand that and i'm so
sorry to hear what you've gone through
and
it's easy to be in your shoes and get
there because i've been there
and i know what it's like to to deal
with the aftermath of a of a broken
marriage obviously 10 years a long time
and i want i i care more about josh
right now than i do about josh's money
it sounds like you're in a fine place
financially but i you need to grieve
this
you need to just take a pause take a
breath there's no urgency around this
the money's gonna be there tomorrow
three months from now six months from
now
so i want you to take a breather and
maybe you get counseling on your own to
grieve and heal and do whatever you need
to do to get josh well
and then we can deal with the money
okay how are you doing
i'm good
okay are there kids involved what's the
ramifications of all this one kid okay
well is everything finalized
no not yet okay
i would let the the dust settle here um
finalize everything and once you have
this pile of money i want you to just
wait
and get some wise counsel
get some people in your corner maybe get
a tax pro
a real estate pro if you're if you're
wanting to get into that later on make
sure you have a financial advisor who's
helping guide this money it sounds like
you've got a good head on your shoulders
on what to do with it um i would put it
towards your next goal you know filter
it through the framework of the baby
steps it sounds like you're debt free
um
more or less there's like 3 000 i o in a
car
and i don't have any credit card debt or
student loan debt okay do you have an
emergency fund in place
yeah yeah i i have
about 40 thousand like 80 000 total
saves and wow half of
passes in a brokerage account and the
other half isn't it yeah bank account i
would i would cash out that brokerage
account i'll get out of that uh the debt
pay that thing off become completely
debt free park that three to six months
of emergency i'd probably lean towards
six months in your situation going
through what you're going through
um are you investing fifteen percent
after that
yeah yeah and i i have like a hundred
and seventy thousand my 401k so
it's like i'm good with retirement
okay so you're on track for a solid
retirement i would get rid of this debt
and just live a debt-free lifestyle
that's gonna take away you already have
enough stress and and drama here and
that debt is just going to add to it so
get out of debt never look back
have that emergency fund look forward to
whatever that house purchase may be down
the road and i would use that money
towards that i wouldn't get into real
estate investing or anything
shiny right now
i would focus it on whatever your next
primary residence is use that as a giant
down payment
aside from your emergency fund while
investing and i don't know what the
financials look like um with the child
in the mix and child support and custody
and all that i'm sure you're still
working some of that out
but i would put it towards that primary
residence and try to get that paid off
and then we can focus on if you want to
do some real estate investing down the
road when you're in baby step seven
that's a fine choice to make
okay all right thank you absolutely josh
i'm so i'm so sorry for what you're
going through man divorce is
so difficult and emotionally taxing
physically taxing financially taxing and
so take your time with this
there's no rush
you're in a good place financially
you've got a big pile of money so just
take care of josh right now and the
money part will take care of itself
later on that puts this hour of the
ramsay show in the books my thanks to
ben hill our producer kelly daniel our
associate producer and phone screener
and you america this is your show and we
appreciate you listening in we'll be
back with you before you know it until
then this has been the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money
i'm george campbell ramsay personality
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
now if you're wondering who this guy is
hosting the show solo
let me fill you in i'm not quite the new
guy i've been on the team here at ramsey
for over eight years
i started as an intern and a temp
back in 2013.
and i followed these steps i came in the
door with forty thousand dollars in debt
and i i realized you know if i'm going
to work here for a long time i want to
follow this plan and make sure it's it
actually works
and so i did that
and i became debt free in about 18
months
and i started following this plan and i
met my wife here she still works here
it's fantastic great carpool buddy
and we had this
big hairy audacious goal to be in baby
step 7 in our early 30s
and in early 2022 we're gonna pay off
our house
and we are so so excited and let me tell
you i'm not i'm not special no
inheritance here no wild incomes just
diligence just decided that we wanted a
different life for our family wanted to
change our family tree
we wanted to be able to live and give
like no one else and take out landish
vacations and do some really fun stuff
and not have to wait until retirement so
that's my heart my hardest to help other
people in their 20s and their 30s get a
hold of this stuff
and realize that they don't have to wait
on the government or some legislation or
the jackpot in order to live their
dreams and live their best financial
life that they could pay off their debt
and they could start investing and have
emergency savings to not have to swipe a
credit card to get by
and so if that's you give me a call
triple eight eight two five five
five i'd love to help you out in any way
i can we're going to go to robert in
knoxville tennessee robert welcome to
the ramsay show
hey good morning thank you for taking my
call absolutely afternoon actually it's
all right time flies when we're having
fun how can i help today
i have a question of uh should i do it
i'm 59 i have no debt no car loans no
student loans oh about 65 000 on the
house and my wife's car is close to 18
years old i've been paid off for a good
10 years at least
and
if my money market account is getting
one half of one percent
and a car loan is going to be expected
to be four and a half five percent
shouldn't i just take it out of savings
and go ahead and pay off the car in full
just be done with it and uh technically
i'm saving four and a half percent right
are you saying to pay for the car in
cash or are you saying you're wanting to
take out a loan
for the car in cash that's what i'm
thinking i should do oh and you're
saying well it's normal for people to
just take out a car loan
and you're saying why would i do that
at four and a half
i don't yeah i mean we're in the boat of
i don't care what the interest rate is
if it's one percent or 70 percent we
think it's dumb to take on any debt of
any kind and that you're better off
paying cash for it especially
depreciating asset like a car
so you've got the right mentality around
it what's this car uh going to cost
uh forty thousand it's a user mercedes
okay
are you guys three years old anyway
yeah what's your household income
uh about eighty five thousand uh we've
got about two hundred thousand in each
other's savings account plus another 350
and two other retirement accounts and i
have a fully funded emergency fund that
is 60 000 just sitting there hold up
you've got 200 000 in cash
oh in the bank sure
and you
have a 65 000 mortgage
yes is it a pet why are you keeping it
around pay this thing off today
i was planning on doing that in early
2022 but why not late 2021
because the
car
was the question
the older car 17 18 years old getting
older and but you've got the money to do
both you could pay off the car and buy
that mercedes today
you could pay off the mortgage
at 59 i've probably got another good
eight years before i retire right
okay
but you've got this money in liquid cash
yes so the question is why are you
holding on to the mortgage
well true too nice point
i mean i if i'm you i want to be debt
free baby step seven living and giving
like no one else today
you guys have worked really hard to to
have all this big pile of money and it's
not working very hard for you when
you're sitting there paying a lender
every month
right
so what do you say okay you pay off the
mortgage today
uh do you have any other vehicles
currently
uh yes have a uh
an old seven uh i don't know chevy
cobalt but that hey
no joke i had i had an 07 chevy cobalt
still runs i think i think i'm talking
to my future self hopefully are you a
millionaire
is your net worth
what is your net worth
oh off the top of my head maybe a half a
million okay
well i mean it's an expensive car uh
based on your income we we have kind of
a parameter that you're everything with
a motor in it should add up to no more
than half of your income and so you're
edging up close to it you're not in
terrible financial shape obviously so
you're okay but i wouldn't go any any
crazier than that car right now
okay and you do have a pile of money so
it makes me feel a whole lot better
about this but uh is the mortgage your
only debt yes sir man i'm getting rid of
that thing
today and i'm gonna be on the car lot
tomorrow and i'm gonna be driving away
with that mercedes and you're still
gonna have plenty of money sitting in
cash in the bank
are you guys on track for retirement
i believe so yes because it sounds like
you're you're heavily weighted in liquid
cash and not a ton in retirement
investing right now is that right
i got two retirement accounts through
various jobs
okay but they they don't add up to more
than a half million total without all of
your assets
no those two are only about uh about 180
to 225 000. yeah that's my only caveat
here is you don't have a ton in
retirement right now if you plan on
retiring soon so i wouldn't if i'm you
i'm taking a pause here and going okay
let me what's best for my financial
future in retirement is it buying a 40
000 car that's going to depreciate in
value or should i really be focused on
building that retirement nest egg so
that i can retire at 65.
okay i gotta wait till 67 don't i
no you don't have to wait everybody
i mean what are you waiting till 67 for
because i like my work i guess oh well
you can keep working but i want to make
sure that you've got enough money to
live on in retirement when you decide i
like to have options i don't know about
you robert but i want to be able to
retire when i want to and not when i
have to so there's no law saying you
have to retire 67 you can work to your
85. i think dave ramsey will he just
loves to work but he could also stop
working today and it'd be no issue
all right
man
sorry you're you're in a good you're
gonna in a good spot robert but uh i
would be questioning this retirement
savings before i jump on this 40 000 car
you got this pile of money i might
invest that money and let it grow so
that you've got a big old retirement
nest egg but you've done a really really
good job and i want to see all this
mortgage uh paid off you got this man
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm george campbell this is the ramsey
show open phone lines this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the last 18 months have been a lot
haven't they a lot of worry a lot of
wondering what would happen next maybe
that's how you feel about your money too
tired stuck stretch thin
but it doesn't have to be that way you
just need a plan
a plan gives you confidence even when
everything else seems out of control
and that plan is financial peace
university this class will teach you
everything you need to know to save
money pay off debt and build wealth for
the future you can stream the lessons on
your own or get support by going through
the class with others then you'll put
that plan into practice with the premium
version of our every dollar budgeting
app
by syncing your bank to your budget you
can easily track your spending and see
where your money goes and you get all of
this only with a ramsay plus membership
you don't have to stay exhausted and
overwhelmed you can win with money to
start your free trial of ramsay plus
text trial to
33789 that's trial two three three seven
eight nine
ken joins us in augusta georgia ken
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you
how can i help today how are you guys
doing great it's just me here it's
lonely but i'm making
it good good deal yeah i just got a
quick question for you um
in the past i've been
sucked up into the leverage leverage
leverage and i'm starting to just look
at different ways of doing stuff and
came across the ramsey in the past three
to six months
um
i've got one vehicle payment and gonna
be paying that off probably within the
next four days four to six weeks okay
but i'll be starting to hit the i'll be
starting to hit the house and i also
have three
investment properties what i'm thinking
about doing is taking the house
and paying that down so it's below the
pmi and then starting hitting the
investment properties
what do you think of that
well i think i think you're trying to do
a lot of things at once right now you've
got some debt is the car loan your only
debt other than the investment
properties in your mortgage
yes do you have a fully funded emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
yes okay so we're in good shape there
if i'm in your shoes i want this primary
mortgage gone before i continue in this
real real estate investing journey
so as far as paying it down i mean if
you're do you do you love all the
properties would you be willing to sell
one in order to pay off your primary
mortgage
well uh someone one wouldn't pay off the
primary mortgage the cash flow
really well they're doing great for me
so i really am not super excited about
selling any of them okay
well at the very least i would i would
attack the primary mortgage first
because you live there if they uh if the
bank comes after the the investment
properties you're going to be okay but
you live in this primary residence so i
want this one gone first
i've heard that also in the past but i
could also sell even if i have
no
mortgage on the investment property i
could still sell that if the bank comes
after me from my personal property
sure i just don't want anyone coming
after you for nothing and so i want to
put myself in a solid financial position
to where i don't have to worry about any
of that and so i want the way we teach
it is you're paying off your primary
residence first before we are building
wealth through investment properties and
so you've already got them and they're
creating cash flow i'm not going to make
you sell them
but i do want you to aggressively pay
off your mortgage and get that out of
your hair
and you'll have even more cash flow then
and then you can work on
paying down the rest of the investment
properties until you have
four paid for properties
yeah i guess what i was looking at also
is i could have all those all those
investment properties paid off in a year
and then come back and pay off the
personal property but i understand what
you're saying
well how soon can you have all four paid
off if you attacked your primary
mortgage
first uh three to four years
well
i'm doing the long game here and getting
rid of that primary mortgage i mean is
this primary mortgage a big chunk of
your income
no um
our gross gross income
is about 350
and the
primary mortgage is
335. the investments are 55. uh the
balance due on the investments is 55.85
and 125.
well you got a fabulous income you could
pay this thing off in no time on your
primary mortgage and then start
attacking those investment properties
that's the way i would do it and that's
that's the way we teach it uh but you do
you can but you're doing great you guys
have a fabulous income and clearly you
you enjoy real estate investing i just
want you to do it in the least risky way
possible and so getting rid of that
primary mortgage is going to be the way
to do that thanks for the call justin
joins us in glendale arizona justin
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks how are you today doing great how
can i help
yeah i got a kind of what would you do
situation oh these are fun me and my uh
right me and my wife are renting we're
renting a house from her grandfather he
decided to sell it to us for around 200
000 and then appraised for 440 right now
wow
he's actually given us 15 in cash on top
to just kind of help out his
granddaughter he was gonna give her the
house free and clear but he decided he
couldn't really do that so this is what
he's doing for us okay um we
we don't have any car loans or any debt
i have maybe
twelve hundred dollars on some credit
cards i was honestly getting ready to
pay off um should i pull out some of
this equity to fix the house up the
house is in good condition but there are
some things that are wrong with it i'd
like to get done
and then also i you know me my wife have
only been married for a couple years and
i don't have
really any real retirement or savings
going right now so do you have an
emergency fund
i have five thousand you got five
thousand and you have 1200 on credit
cards
yep dude pay that credit card off today
is that the only debt in your life
that's about it right now what's about
it is there more here
what's the full story oh there's no no
that's it i had one i have one credit
card i'm an avid hunter so i have one
credit card i was using to put stuff on
to get the points
we'll let that go about six months road
revolving and rotating and then i end up
paying it off when my hunting season's
over
well look at that here's what i'm going
to tell you to do go listen to our
credit card rewards episode of the fine
print hopefully that'll change your mind
on this whole rewards thing it's a scam
man and uh i don't want you falling for
it anymore you guys have a bright future
you've got an incredible opportunity
here but what you're asking me is should
we use a heloc to get this house fixed
up correct correct
the answer to that is a resounding no
uh the heloc is going to put your home
at risk
it's probably going to have a variable
interest rate and it's going to set you
guys back in the long run and so what i
would do is cash flow these repairs as
you can uh can you get into this
you're you're in the house right now
we are renting
uh it's in escrow right now i should
close on the 30th okay and you can
afford this mortgage
absolutely all right on and are you
getting a 15-year fixed
uh it's 30 here oh boy is it too late to
switch
yeah oh boy okay well glad i caught you
at least in this moment to stop you from
from doing the heloc what we recommend
is 25 of your take-home pay on a 15-year
fix that's what i want the mortgage to
be uh because i don't want you to be
house poor but on the heloc side
absolutely do not do don't mess with a
heloc don't do that okay
it's going to be a nightmare and when
you go through that line of credit it's
going to come
that balance is going to come due in
full and the bank can take your home and
so this is putting you in a real risky
financial position
that i don't want you guys in as you uh
you know you're in this the early stages
of this marriage i want as little
anxiety as possible so avoid the heloc
cash flow the repairs as you can make
them you said it's livable there's
nothing on fire here cash flow these
repairs as quickly as you can you've got
some money but i need you to build that
fully funded emergency fund as soon as
you pay off those credit cards
and you can do that all within a few
months and then start to cash flow these
repairs soon after that
that's what i figured i just wanted to
get in i appreciate you taking my call
and kind of letting you bounce some
ideas off yeah absolutely justin happy
to help that is what i'm here for i
appreciate that open phone lines this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five you heard me mention that
episode on the fine print we dug into
the rat race of credit card rewards uh
in episode two of the fine print you can
find that wherever you listen to
podcasts and man
it was fascinating i'll tell you we go
through a journey on that podcast it's
about 30 minutes or less and it's a
great thing to send to your friends your
family who are convinced that they've
got to play their credit card reward
game they've got to get their points got
to get the cash back got to take the
free vacations there's no such thing as
a free lunch man and these credit card
companies are taking you to the cleaners
and you don't even know it
go listen to the fine print wherever you
listen to podcasts this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell ramsey personality
and you are listening to the ramsay show
before the break i was talking about my
podcast the fine print available on the
ramsey network and what we do in this
podcast is really dig into the hidden
truths that are keeping people broke
you see i have this crazy belief that if
you follow the trends you will fall for
the traps
and what i hate seeing
is young people especially in their 20s
and 30s following the trends
here's what they do
here's what we teach our kids kids you
got to build credit early that's the way
to a solid financial future
so what do you do you give the kid a
credit card at 18 years old and let them
take out two hundred thousand dollars
worth of debt before they can take a
drink of alcohol
this is america
wow
land of the free home of the broke
and then we wonder why our kids are
graduating crippled with student loan
debt
worried about building their credit
score
they can't start families they can't buy
houses they're frustrated at the boomers
and the economy for screwing them over
and i'm sick of it
i think we
can live differently and i have done it
and we recently released this episode
episode 7 on the fine print the dirty
truth behind your credit score
and i i dig into the myth of the credit
score with a scalpel and the even bigger
myth that you can't live without one
and what's the big reasons people say i
need a credit score well you need a
credit score
a good one when you want debt
and we teach people that you don't need
debt to live your life
and therefore if you're doing some easy
math at home you realize that if i'm
going to be debt free and live a
debt-free lifestyle then the credit
score is irrelevant
and when i paid off my debt years ago
i my credit score became what's called
indeterminable
it's not really zero it just i become
invisible when it comes to my credit
history
and guess what i found out i could still
pay for a car in cash they let you do
that and i could still rent an apartment
if i had income
and i wasn't a criminal
and so on this episode
i called up apartments across the
country i called up rental houses and i
asked them and you'll hear it on the
podcast if i can rent without a credit
score and every single one said uh yeah
that's fine i mean as long as it's not a
terrible credit score that shows you're
terrible with money and as long as
you're not a criminal and you have a job
i'd be happy to rent you okay great
and we talked to a mortgage professional
a mortgage loan expert named seth and he
walked me through what's called manual
underwriting when when getting a
mortgage and uh this isn't theory this
is a process i actually used
to buy my house
manual underwriting because when i went
to apply for the mortgage i didn't have
a credit score
and there's a way around that too you
see back in the olden days there were no
credit scores to determine if you were
credit worthy if you were worthy of
taking on this loan and so banks had to
look at your actual life your financial
history how much money you make do you
pay your bills on time and that's what
this process is sometimes you'll hear it
called a no score loan
and so that's what i did
it is possible
renting a car i've done that as well
we're sitting here in the dollar car
rental studio you can use a debit card
when you rent cars i've done it multiple
times traveled all around the country
with no issues
getting hotel room same deal
and people tell me well george your
insurance rates and all these things and
your my job checks my cr what they're
checking for is do you have terrible
credit have you not paid your bills to
where we can't trust you with this money
if you have no score it's a very
different situation so i encourage you
guys to go listen to this episode it's
30 minutes long it's narrative it's
something different we've never done
anything like this before on the ramsey
network
unless you've listened to borrowed
future similar style we weave in and out
of experts and real stories that we find
and some fun monologues
so i encourage you to go listen to this
uh to hopefully maybe change your
perspective on the idea of the credit
score good stuff there we also have a
bonus episode uh in the feed right now
episode eight student loans are back is
the crisis worse than ever and we update
you guys if you've listened to borrowed
future on the ramsey network that was an
eight episode series we did in 2019 this
is an update episode two years later and
i dig in with experts we hear stories we
get updates and it's a good time it's
about an hour long good stuff in that
episode as well so go check it out you
can go to fineprintpodcast.com or search
for the fine print wherever you listen
to podcasts austin is with us in boise
idaho austin welcome to the ramsay show
hi george how are you i'm doing great
how are you man how can i help
um so i'm a junior in high school and i
mow lawns around my neighborhood
and
so i've saved up about twenty seven
thousand dollars whoa it's just sitting
in my bank account dude way to go and
i don't know what to do with it because
i know i'm gonna go to college in a
couple of years and so i'll probably
need some of it but my dad also has
a 529 account for me and that has he's
predicting it'll have about forty to
forty five thousand dollars in it
in a couple of years when i go to go to
college
and i'm also
planning on serving a two-year mission
for my church after my first year of
college dude yeah unicorn
the expenses for that mission are only
400 a month so i'm definitely not going
to need all of my money
um
immediately of course i'll use it to go
to college debt free but i was just
wondering should i be investing it
should i have in just a high yield
savings account like i have which really
isn't that high yield
in fact it's very low yield yeah or
should i put it in a certificate of
deposit or is there something i should
be doing with my money that i'm not
already
uh well first of all you are crushing it
i mean you many americans are like this
kid's a junior in high school and he's
doing better than me financially it's
time to make a change
and your dad has got a great head on his
shoulders it's so awesome that he's got
that 529 set up for you and he's been
throwing money in there
so yeah what i would do with that money
you're doing the right thing putting in
a high yield savings account because
this is money that you may need in the
next year or two years right
yeah
so i wouldn't go investing this into uh
into the market right now because you've
got a short time horizon where you may
need this money so your a1 is investing
in austin right now which you're doing a
great job of you are you have you're not
scared of work and so you've got this
27k i want to make sure that you can go
to college debt free do you have plans
to definitely go to college
yeah i do
where at do you have any idea
well i was hoping byu that's an option
or montana state or i could stay close
to home and go to boise state that's
right in the backyard love it so we're
talking in-state affordable schools here
yeah boise state would be in state and
byu is pretty cheap montana state would
be the
dream if i could get a scholarship there
yeah i mean i think at this point apply
for all the scholarships you can but be
ready to pay for it in cash and choose
the most affordable option make sure
that your your
education matches your goal do you know
what you want to study
some kind of engineering i think i'd
like mechanical engineering to sound
cool but no i'm not completely sure
fantastic we'll start to dig into that
and see what it's like maybe you shadow
a mechanical engineer for a day and go
wow i love this or oh my gosh i can't
imagine having to do this every day
so you've got time to figure that out
and you've got a nice pile of money
between the 529 and your money here i'm
i'm counting up um 72
that you guys have right now
that you could use towards your
education i know you said you've got
that mission piece that you want to do
for two years and that's about five
grand a year give or take
uh which you're obviously going to cash
flow so uh how you use the money i think
we're going to use that towards college
and if we're not sure yet i would still
park it in that high yield savings
account keep throwing money in that 529
through through your dad that's awesome
and then once you get through college we
can see what's left over you might need
it all right or you might have
20 grand left over and then you can use
that towards your emergency fund you can
use that to start investing use that as
a down payment on your first house all
kinds of life goals but i would not put
it in anything riskier than a high yield
savings account right now i know it's
sad you're like it's growing at 5.5
percent this sucks
that's okay yeah the best thing you can
do is keep investing in austin keep
growing that uh savings that you have
right now it's so awesome you've got the
side hustle and it's crushing man way to
go happy to hear it
thanks keep us posted on the journey man
did you hear that
america a junior in high school
has a higher net worth than most of you
i'm not here to shame you
but i am here to tell you that we could
do better
and that there is hope in the next
generation don't tell me that gen z
sucks
austin's crushing it this kid's a
unicorn
we all should aspire to be like this guy
so much good stuff happening there happy
to hear austin's story i want more of
that
in 2020 too i'm here for it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
proverbs 16 16
how much better to get wisdom than gold
to get insight rather than silver
oscar wilde said nowadays people know
the price of everything and the value of
nothing good stuff there
our question of the day comes from
blinds.comblinds.com
100 satisfaction guarantee means even if
you mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free i
like that you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
you can use promo code ramsey to get the
best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from josh in idaho
as we're getting close to the end of the
year i'm planning ahead to make sure i
have everything i need to fill out my
tax returns i usually do them myself but
i started my own business in january so
it's not going to be a simple return
this time around
should i try to do it myself or would it
be better to use one of the online
services like turbotax
great question josh now i'm a fan of
doing your taxes online if you've got a
simple situation
i am not a fan of turbo tax and uh the
reason you can find out in episode one
of the fine print podcast
me and dave ramsey we dug into their
shareholder presentation
and turbo tax is taking a
a big turn
they are turning into
basically a big financial company one of
the biggest lenders in the world and so
their job is to use turbo tax
as a front door and then use all of your
information to then sell you debt down
the line and that's aside from a lot of
horror stories i've heard with customer
service issues and turbo tax doing some
things wrong and the irs is involved so
for those reasons and the fact that you
own a business now things are a lot more
complicated and so absolutely i am using
attacks pro
and lucky for you we've got uh some
great pros that we trust all around the
country to help you with all of your tax
needs they are called endorsed local
providers
and if you jump onto ramseysolutions.com
click on trusted pros click on taxes we
can connect you with one of these tax
pros in your area who can help you do
things the ramsay way they have a heart
of a teacher and they're going to help
you make sure that you don't get screwed
you don't fill out the wrong box you're
saving all the money you can not giving
too much to uncle sam
all of that good stuff and they are
ramsey trusted we trust them to help our
fans out appreciate the question
all right let's go to daniel in kansas
city missouri daniel welcome to the
ramsay show
george what is up dude how's it going oh
it's going great this has been a fun
show so far happy to talk with you how
can i help
nice um so my question is about the
emergence fund
i have
a small amount saved it's only about 2
700 but the unique thing is that
represents about four months for me
because i'm
pretty good at living frugally wow um
the um the unique thing though is that
uh i've had like a couple emergencies
just this year
and i built it back up time and time
again but like
earlier this year in may i had about
eight thousand saved in my emergency
fund and a lady hit me and didn't have
insurance
so i had to spend my emergency fund to
buy a new car in cash
are you okay
yeah i'm okay it was just uh i was
delivering pizza and she just um hit me
from the side
but uh
i uh
yeah i had to spend
the money
on a new car so i bought a cash and
borrowing money but it's tricky to know
like exactly how much to save because
that could happen again and it might be
more than my six months expenses to buy
a new car what do you recommend for for
that situation well uh it's a great
question i don't want you to live in
fear and paranoia here most people are
gonna have insurance and so you ran into
a tricky situation and i'm guessing that
you did not have uninsured motorist
coverage on your policy
that was the thing is that i had
uninsured motorists um but for for my
state at the time it only covers um
medical damages and not vehicle damages
some drum law i guess i'm congressman
yeah i might i might jump on and see if
there's a different policy that would
cover something like that in the future
um i don't know what company you have
you can jump onto
ramseysolutions.com click on trusted
pros and we have uh property and
casualty insurance pros that can help
you with things like auto insurance and
they can see in your state are there
policies that would cover something like
that in the future if that's a fear of
yours obviously it's warranted because
of what you went through
as far as the emergency fund goes if i'm
you there's nothing wrong with having
six months of savings there what would
that be for you
so that would be about 3 800.
okay i mean are you in a good spot
debt-free obviously
yeah yeah so i'm debt-free
i'm investing
fifteen percent i do six percent up to
the match in my 401k i put the remainder
in the roth um
i have some i have a couple taxable
investing accounts
um i have ugmas from my niece and nephew
dude you were crushing it how old are
you
i'm 24. oh my gosh i just dropped my pen
when did you find out about this stuff
uh
the ramsay plan yeah
well it was um curriculum in my high
school
and then
i grew up in first assembly of god so it
was it was in there too
and i always knew that that was dumb
but um
i used to work at an outdoor store like
a camping store
and they said oh if you get this new
credit card then we'll give you a 100
gift card and i was like you know i'll
just paid off
um but i i didn't and so i got a little
bit of debt went on a mission strip came
back and decided to pay off the debt and
start the ransom plan that was um march
of 2020. wow did the lord convict you on
this mission trip and was like bro you
got to be debt-free
yes he definitely did look at that
what a beautiful story on the credit
card that's awesome well yeah man i
would i would lean towards six months if
i'm you and my guess is your expenses
are going to increase over time so you
need to increase your emergency fund
over time i would not live in fear over
the car
issue but you know you can beef it up to
six months call it five grand and you'll
be able to buy an upgraded car over time
as you save and you'll be just fine
thanks for the call man quentin joins us
in san antonio texas quinton welcome to
the ramsay show
hey thank you for having me today yeah
how can i help
so i'm 21 years old um he's got a small
family i'm about to get married i've got
a two-year-old son well he's about to
see next week
and i don't want to rent the rest of my
life um
i'm just trying to figure out what steps
do i need to take to save up and and
eventually buy a house in the next two
to three years
okay what's your household income
right now for us we
are probably
lower 50s altogether
i am about to start uh i'm looking into
being a police officer um over in san
antonio so i know my income would would
definitely jump up from that
um but yeah right now about lower to mid
50s okay
well it's a simple math equation and
we've got a great mortgage calculator
over at ramseysolutions.com
uh you click on free tools there and
jump on there but what it comes down to
is not being house poor so i know you
don't want to rent forever but i also
don't want you to be house poor and have
this mortgage payment taken over your
life as you try to start off this
marriage with a two-year-old and so what
i would do if i were you is start
looking at what houses cost in the area
and then set a goal and say all right
the house is 300 000
and if we're going to have this mortgage
payment be under 25 of our take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed rate mortgage here's
how much we would need to save for the
down payment
and so then you know your down payment
goal now we have a very tactical goal we
want to save 60 000 in three years
that's 20 grand a year how are we going
to do that well it might mean taking on
a side job it might mean
getting a new job and getting some extra
income coming in and so you guys need to
decide what that looks like for you but
it might also mean you need to adjust
your expectations and your time horizon
and go all right the houses are that we
want is 350 000. are we willing to not
get that house right now and get a 200
000 condo
or are we okay waiting five years and
getting that house so that it's uh
inside of those parameters does that
make sense
yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah so
i'm rooting for you man congrats on the
marriage and everything you've got going
on and i know man renting
you're just like man i'm throwing money
away now you're not you're buying time
you're buying patience that's what it
comes down to and if you want to listen
to one of the episodes in the fine print
we did on this is now the worst time to
buy a house we dig into the housing gold
rush and everything going on with that
crisis and i think it's going to give
you a lot of hope uh rachel cruz will
walk you through the green lights as to
when you're ready to buy a house we
talked to brian biffini real estate
industry analyst we talked to a guy who
foreclosed back in 2008 because he
jumped in because he was like you i
don't want to waste money on rent
oh
guys
it's been a fun show
solo for the first time we did it no
incidents no accidents my thanks to ben
hill our producer associate producer and
phone screener kelly daniel the guys in
the video booth zac and nathan our
marketer alicia mackey just everyone has
been just a joy to work with and you
america thank you so much for listening
it's been an absolute blast to be your
host today until next time spend wisely
save intentionally and give generously
this has been the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you